yeah that's good even these rim rocks
are pretty worn but most importantly
everything blow the ground levels
red-hot under their mats putting the
finishing touches on the perimeter kid
he'll use the roasts his wild turkey but
it's a delicate process any missteps
could cost him hard-earned meat so right
now taking the horse still lining the
pit so I can put the turkey and it won't
burn any type of green rich rich plant
work well for this as long as it's not
poisonous put a little more water crust
on the top really seal that him there's
always the possibility and don't get
enough grass around again and then the
bird burns some certain spots whew these
rocks I'll try to get in just feel a
little bit more heat trapped in there
whenever you build it that's the biggest
concern is making sure you get it hot
enough everything's in the right
position okay that's probably all the
rocks I can fit in there yeah good
heating there even when cut off from
oxygen a thick bed of hot coals can
generate heat for up to three days this
is looking pretty good
at this point you gotta get her ceiling
really fast
and you see a steam on escape it's a
good sign so this covering really holds
in the heat
yeah this is great so what I'm doing
right now is putting the fire back on
cuz by putting on the coals I'm gonna
get some radiant heat that's gonna push
down and keep that capstone warm so that
way the heat that's already in there
won't escape
so hopefully I got it got it all good
this time
we'll see